vous avez eu un accident agen stade en
commun pendant trois semaines entre la
vie et la mort j'ai eu de la chance
non pas tellement le vert téléphone il
décharge et j'avais du relais et je sais
pas il est déchargé
on est où là
pour aller à la force des rousses je
reconnais que je vois la forge 0 106
lahoun si l'entrée du mois c'est là que
j'y arrive en 4 4 route de l'apa
vous
vous venez tout
je suis
mais vous venez d'où vers la route tel
autre à voir les loueurs autres
c'est d'oser direction voyez mmm est sur
le bon chemin
j'ai rendez vous
la fois
tu marches du crime tout il faut que j'y
aille là où j'allais vers les roches
c'est quoi ça les roches je suis perdu
10 au matin j'ai perdu mon chien m'a
volé mon fusil
j'ai dormi dans une crotte le matin on
m'avait pris mon fusil sans déconner